le docteur 27 avec nous encore ce soir
bonsoir dr weiss j'ai quelques questions
pour vous une question assez important
dans le contexte actuel où on se prépare
on déconfinement progressif
combien de temps selon les dernières
études durent l'immunité des gens qui
ont eu la coville 19
alors la réponse on la sait pas aller la
réponse est très simple on sait pas
puisque adapte premièrement on est au
début de faire des tests de sérologie
donc les têtes où on se fait chier des
anticorps ou pas et on la plupart du
temps évidemment les gens ne seraient
infecte pas quand on a eu des cas entre
guillemets qui ont été apportées comme
les réinfection c'était plus des
problèmes de laboratoire donc on sait
pas actuellement mais habituellement ce
genre de virus
souvent les gens vont avoir une ligne et
à long terme donc si le virus ne change
pas beaucoup si le virus ne mute pas
beaucoup et devient très différentes
il est actuellement il n'est
habituellement pas le cas pour les
coronavirus l'immunité habituellement si
on a une bonne immunité avec des
anticorps qu'on appelle neutralisant ça
peut durer longtemps mais la réponse
actuelle ça ces théories pour ce cas là
on ne la connaît pas puis on le souhaite
évidemment parce que si jamais
l'immunité devait être beaucoup plus
brève
ben ça compliquerait pas mal échange
d'un cas pas de vaccin il ya comme deux
scénarios il ya le scénario d'agréer
d'influenza ou donc là vous faites
vacciner mais si vous faites pas
vacciner vous avez déjà fait la grippe a
vous êtes protégé mais au bout d'un
certain nombre d'années le virus qui va
circuler va est tellement différent du
lyrisme que vous avez rencontrées que
vous redevenez susceptible alors si à un
moment donné on fait ça le corona qu'on
rencontrera s'il est encore là qui
change beaucoup dans dix ans mais il
sera très différente c'est pas je vous
dis c'est pas le scénario habituel des
coronavirus ou bien on a au contraire
des anticorps neutralisants un peu comme
la varicelle hélas ce moment là vous
avez fait la varicelle une fois dans
votre vie
et puis après ça vous êtes protégé
pendant très longtemps jusqu'à ce que
peut être très vieux vous fassiez un
zona mais ça devient une autre histoire
bon
alors espérons que l'immunité va va
durer le port du masque on y revient
parce que là ça va s'accélérer
il y aura des distributions en tout cas
ils ont recommandé fortement dans les
transports en commun dans une ville
comme montréal
vous êtes totalement d'accord vous
l'avais dit à plusieurs reprises
totalement d'accord depuis très
longtemps qu'il faut mettre du mas il ya
des masses universel pour tout le monde
la seule chose encore une fois il faut
le répéter le mas n'est pas une panacée
c'est à dire que le mas est une mesure
qui additionné aux autres mesures garde
toute son efficacité
donc ça veut pas dire maintenant que
j'ai un mas que je peux je me lave les
mains je me mets un proche de tout le
monde que je peux pousser dans dans mon
masque sans faire attention que je n'ai
que je ne respecte plus tout ce qui a
été donné comme consigne autres
précédemment
donc le mas c'est un plus un plus un
plus un pour que un plus un plus un plus
un égale à dix ça l'idée d'avoir un
masque mais non pas un tout seul ça ne
remplace rien exactement c'est une
fausse sécurité il faut pas faut pas non
plus dire vous savez c'est comme si
quelqu'un dirait moi je mets ma ceinture
de sécurité puis à partir de là je peux
aller prendre la boisson ne pas
respecter les lumières conduire etc
mais j'ai ma ceinture de sécurité donc à
ce moment là il va falloir les gens et
et un équilibre entre les deux très bien
c'est clair je dois aller demande une
dame qui nous a appelés au téléphone je
dois aller à l'hôpital pour des prises
de sang pour un suivi de cancer comment
ça se passe dans les salles d'attentes
est ce risqué parce que la ministre de
la santé encore dit cette semaine
allez-y appeler vos médecins bah oui on
veut que les gens nous appellent et les
gens nous appellent indique t on est là
pour s'occuper des patients les là pour
s'occuper des gens sont malades alors
n'hésitez surtout pas à appeler votre
médecin c'est important d'aller le voir
même à l'hôpital si vous devez aller
voir lorsque des conditions urgente
lorsqu'il ya des conditions où c'est
nécessaire de voir les patients
on les voit si vous devrez dans les
centres de prélèvement les centres de
prélèvement sont ouverts il ya des
règles précises au niveau des centres de
prélèvement mais s'il vous plaît ne riez
pas peur d'aller à l'hôpital c'est
important d'y aller en respectant les
rênes et n'ayez pas peur d'appeler votre
médecin
qui prend avait besoin parce que sinon
vous allez avoir des complications on a
vu par exemple des gens qui présentait
plus parce qu'ils avaient des problèmes
des douleurs dans la poitrine
celui-ci ne venez pas assez rapidement
l'auteur il faut pas que les gens
pensent les gens conçu comme consulter
avons exactement donc vous c'est sans
hésitation vous êtes revenez
si vous avez besoin d'y aller alesi
n'hésitez pas parce que ce qui a tenté
souvent plus dangereux que d'attraper la
coved 19 dans ce cas si nous entendons
très bien nous entendons beaucoup parler
de la coved 19
mais qu'en est il de la grippe
saisonnière est elle encore présentes ou
sellal la loi du plus fort comme si la
coved avait tué t'amusant cette question
là comme si la commune avait tué la
grippe
écoutez c'est une question très
intéressante et là je vais vous dire
pourquoi parce qu'on a on va vite
tellement d'énergie on s'est tellement
concentré à faire des tests pour le coc
guide qu'on l'a tué de délestage et
arrêter de tester pour l'influenza de
faire donc pour la grippe
il ya déjà quelques semaines donc on ne
connaît plus les idéologies dati nasa au
tibet et en plus avec tout le
confinement avec tout ce qu'on a mis
comme mesure probablement que ça a eu un
impact extrêmement important ça aurait
été très intéressant d'un point de vue
biologique d'étudier ce phénomène mais
on n'avait pas les capacités de faire à
la fois la mise en place des tests pour
le coc vie et continuer à tester pour
l'influenza
mais il est clair qu'on est vers la fin
de la saison et qui avait tout le
compliment qu'on a fait une infinie rosa
ne veut pas être présent bon alors je
profite de votre présence à en bouclant
la boucle sur le masque bon quel type de
tissu
vous pourriez recommandé de menton coton
polyester pour se confectionner un
masque à la maison et pts et je ne sais
pas exactement j'ai pas une réponse
adéquate pour ça
l'objectif c'est d'avoir une barrière
physique donc tout ce qui est une
barrière physique avec un tissu assez
épais où les cibles sont assez
enchevêtrées et une quelque chose qui va
permettre tout simplement au d'arrêter
les deux virus parce que n'oubliez pas
vous mettez un masque principalement
pour vous pour ne pas vous parler quand
vous tous et que si vous êtes porteur du
virus
vous en voyez pas des sécrétions dégoûte
est autour de vous pour infecter
d'autres personnes et dans le sens
contraire il ya possiblement une
protection mais elle est mal connu et si
on a une à ce moment là mais c'est parce
que il faut que le masque une certaine
épaisseur à certains tissus donc sa part
demande importance tant qu il faut
courir votre nez faut courir votre
bouche vous que le masque soit assez
grand pour bien couvrir bas du menton
jusqu'aux os du nez et qui soit assez
épais pour qu'ils aient une certaine
efficacité mais donc au polyester
je sais bien qu'on n'a pas la réponse il
faut le dire mais l'on comprend très
bien le principe de ce que vous avez
expliqué comment ça va à l'hôpital en
terminèrent docteur comment ça va dans
votre les hôpitaux sont stables mais il
faut faire attention c'est que on a vu
cette semaine des éclosions niveau des
hôpitaux et il faut s'assurer qu'on
garde nos hôpitaux au québec on a
réussit actuellement je dirais à
contenir le virus quand les gardes entre
guillemets propres up de covile 19
parce que si on veut recommencer à
travailler il faut s'assurer que les
hôpitaux ne devienne pas contaminés et
qu'on introduise donc le virus et que
l'on commence à faire les chirurgies
commencé à prêter des patients parce
qu'il faut pas oublier qu'on doit faire
ça il faut qu'on recommence donc tout ça
mis ensemble
il va falloir s'assurer de garder une
hôpitaux le plus propre possible et
c'est ce qu'on est enceinte on s'évertue
à faire actuellement
mais il faut qu'on continue de faire des
efforts dans ce sens là d'où le retour
graduel à qu'on le répète beaucoup dans
le retour graduel
il faut remonter de façon tranquille en
terme de nos activités faut qu'on ait un
plan devrait débuter des activités parce
qu'on peut pas laisser les patients qui
ont besoin de traitement sans avoir
accès à l'hôpital
il faut qu'on reprenne des cliniques
externes il faut qu'on reprenne
l'oncologie des chirurgies et dr weiss
merci beaucoup bonne fin de semaine
vous aussi